[Music]
and but why you why they don't care that
was my favorite Jojo what's better
porque pero por que por que what's the
difference between poor K and K for K Y
cares what what about kaizo choice
cheese oh wait wait wait I have a trick
that I learned in childhood I have to
show it to you guys okay go okay so okay
is is so is so is okay so what kind of
trick you hide your right if you're
right qu es oh you can like spell it out
like it yes is so and so is lost my
answer no what do you say no okay so
cheese Oh what is cheese cheese is
cheese somebody fixed me in the comments
or K is why for the case why so submit
it by fantastic Mike was are you yeah
what's fantastic me with the pH last
name what's not fan alright so a woman
who tossed a chair off a high-rise
balcony turned herself into a police
after the video went viral
oh my god I know which one this is you
do yeah she wasn't a balcony she grabbed
the chance she just where who just like
fell down down down down down on a
freeway you dude hit a car mad dangerous
you can't see because it cameras turn
back to her alright I'm immature cuz I
would like to see that it wasn't Canada
and Canada Police tweeted about it
saying they were looking for her if
anybody knew who she was there on a
horse that's like committing a murder in
Canada yeah I mean that can't commit a
murder even Mountie even throwing a
[ __ ] penny over the belt over a
balcony of like 10 stories can [ __ ] it
turns into a nuclear missile it can
injure someone basically it can like it
can like nuclear missile really no it's
good yeah they say that I think apart
state building a penny will [ __ ] make
a huge indent in the ground or something
gravity acceleration M Squared's
whatever now so when you're on a high
like building dough don't you just want
to throw things know
I do but I get scared because I know
gravity and the acceleration and all
that gravity I just I don't your mayor
no yeah yeah you know when you throw
something when you throw something off
of a high place like a mountain or
whatever your balls shrink until that
thing hits the floor you ever get that
feeling like you throw something yo even
like a glass bottle or something you
know and you're like I totally hits the
nerves yo why are you I just science
what happens to girls is just that's
just what happens to me Dawson I got
that I got the Sun maybe we keep all
that I get I get scared yeah you get
scared carrying the blood started blood
the rest of the blood has to go to your
heart cuz your should pump it harder
like you know what you have trash right
and like got thrown away the trash can
when you're throwing it when it's in the
air like please go and please Lord
please go no I'm not that nervous about
your haul if I may be a mountain I get
the same feeling but just like a roller
coaster sweeping turns slow boat to you
I [ __ ] hate him I hate roller coaster
I hate I get that feeling
I understand me but I get it anyway so
this woman let me show you the video
clip first oh yeah she's 19 years old
what is anyway what is she doing she met
oh it's a snapchat oh it's just for
content my balls are shrinking my balls
are shrinking do you do it for the
content that's crazy huh that is [ __ ]
crazy I wonder what happened to her kids
are so stupid she's 19
she's not a kid anymore so police said
that two chairs among other items were
thrown off shoot what is it what else
she huh kid I don't know they said
another item so they were looking for
her but she ended up turning herself in
because the police ended up saying like
we know who you are we're giving you
time to talk to your lawyer so just turn
yourself in oh that's good I didn't even
know there like this works
well if he said the Fiat I mean probably
that they had a lot of cattle tells tip
yeah tattletale saying that they knew
who she was official statement tethered
sure huggers I know yeah and so her name
is Marcela stupid idiot with mischief
and endangering life mister damaging
property under $5,000 and common
nuisance I bet you was girls that hated
her at high school I know that [ __ ]
Marcella
cher hooker oh my god she can like I
definitely released you did affirm the
content yeah
content she looks like someone who wants
to be she's really pretty stupid [ __ ]
she's really stupid pretty [ __ ] yeah
she I forgive you Marcella we all make
mistakes ik Allah all the guys all the
[ __ ] people at the police station
were like oh she she's already she's
really that's right they're like we know
who you are Instagram turn yourself in I
know that chair just randomly slipped
out your hands sometimes those plastic
chairs can be slippery it happens to the
best of us pretty girls like you don't
do things like that yeah you didn't mean
to
oh yeah there is no like she hasn't
given an explanation to why she she did
this oh you like do you even need an
explanation though I mean like when
you're 19 and you see a chair don't you
want to throw it over know what the
caption saying good morning or something
good morning I kind of like it just like
my cell Marcela's alright not my type
but it is just yeah you were all like oh
my god murderer I mean what she did is
pretty [ __ ] up but I guess I can't say
[ __ ] because I personally want to do
things like that but I I'm older now and
I know that something can happen like
after that chair leaves there might be
something at the bottom even that 19 you
couldn't think like you couldn't press
what my guys are stupid cars under that
you would have done it in 18 yeah but a
a chair would fall on the car and then
bounce off you don't remember doing dumb
[ __ ] at 19 I was a mom by 1900 when I
was 19 I was pretty dumb I don't think I
would have blown this hair like I
probably thrown like a like a ball
toilet paper roll or something yeah it's
back you know I believe that you were
the same guy though in your 20s that
would grab change from your [ __ ] car
Oh
and throw it at other cars windows
that's cuz they [ __ ] with me what if
that's your [ __ ] freeway [ __ ] that
freeway I hate the 405 not the
difference is this so I wouldn't hurt
innocent people but okay Batman what do
you rob to get the criminals with these
pennies so if they're like just innocent
people just driving like could be like
some old geezer whatever I'm not gonna
hurt them but while I was on the freeway
and some other dude cut me off that guy
trying to [ __ ] with me so now it's
personal it's all grabbing the change so
he's not doing it as a prank and for fun
but I'm talking about he did this when
he was younger
well I'm looking like I shouldn't do
that now because I get pissed off too
no that's probably bad anymore like that
I do I'm like guys I know and I remember
that the other day I was like trying to
cut this girl off I was trying to cut
this girl off is your name Marcel
Marcela so I go on this late and then
she speeds up and there's a car park and
she like speeds up to not let me in and
then I [ __ ] have to go behind her
again and then I was like and then I was
like oh I was like Kay so it's so I
gotta get into that part of my life but
it's really hard I don't know how to
like be a little angry sometimes it just
a little angry turns into a lot of pain
yeah me too and I'm really I'm a pretty
calm first I just got a drive light oh
go ahead
that's what I do that's why today is a
good day yeah me and I think at that age
you know maybe like 21 or 22 it was me
and my other buddy and then my other
homie who is a gangster
we were driving or just going somewhere
normal and then there's like this
lowrider that pulls up next to me and
like you I'm always trying to be nice in
the beginning so I am I kidding yeah
well back up I mean I slow down a little
bit
signal on and after this guy gets in
front of me he flips me off and I'm like
I let you get in front of him and I
threw at me
what's up then and he pulled up his
shirt like this and then ah sigh oh my
homies in the back so he said follow us
to the freeway so we parked on the
freeway I would never do on my home you
have held guns in his back we pull up to
the silo 3-mile when we pop this trunk
we look down there they already passed
away so I was like I was like after that
I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] can get crazy
real quick yeah so you stop throwing
pennies you still want to do that I just
wanted throw pennies and leave that's
how things can get it's dangerous some
dude followed me home one time I don't
yeah I didn't even I don't think I Drive
I'm more like Joe now like my whole life
even since I got my license 16 I was
always chill I never tried to cut people
off I don't really drive fast like I've
had some faster cars but I don't really
do nothing and it was on my parents when
I was probably 17 18 and I don't think I
cut anybody off I can't remember but I
remember parking my parents driveway and
looking in like a Ford Explorer cuts me
off so I can leave and I'm sitting on my
car and I just look at my River Mira
it's like an old dude though 17 is dudes
like old fat white and he gets out his
car and so like I fake I fake it on the
phone which are you silent Mike but all
my fault like faking like who knows what
right just so like this [ __ ]
Lisa and I sat there for like 10 minutes
he just stared me down also what is this
guy gonna do
goddamn kid like he's just standing
looking at all the end about driveway
and we're out there like a residential
maybe he thought you were hot maybe one
too [ __ ] ya fat noodle I mean what was
he gonna do is like I'm gonna just yell
at your punch a kid yeah people are
crazy and I'm a [ __ ] I'm not like bard
I'm not throwing pennies so I was just
sit in the car till he left pennies went
out yeah when I was like 18 19 and I got
road rage I would just try to hit that
car with my you play too many video
games I don't know all the movies rolls
like that yeah like one time this car I
guess like I was just tailgating - too
hard so they you know how some people
purposely yeah yeah and then same thing
like people they almost come to a
complete stop throw the middle finger
all that stuff right so I just like BAM
hit him from the back I didn't they got
out of the car and I was with one of my
crazy buddies and he had this thing at
the time where he loved carrying samurai
swords and they were like yelling and
then my friend just pulled like got out
of I feel like crazy drive-ins like the
Norman LA if I see somebody pause summer
I sort out I'm laughing like I'm [ __ ]
laughing at you yeah thankfully that guy
got in the car and drove away
back in those things it's like God I
think even cars boot you would just see
what was happening to the homies and the
homies would take turns bowling that car
yeah so like let's say they go oh what
the [ __ ] I feel trying to cut the homie
off
so you would go in front of them and
they'll break check-in my 20 times
anyway if I don't break check it might
we that we eight cars deep and it like
try to be in a lie I'm not excusing what
she did like I forgot already so stupid
but that you have so much time that
you'd like and if your friend and your
petty as [ __ ] yeah and if your friends
are idiots to everybody to hurt you it's
like a circle of [ __ ] morons going
you do some more [ __ ] [ __ ] and now with
social media it's just all escalated
because your [ __ ] to get more attention
those pretty nice so [ __ ] this [ __ ]
she's stupid she probably got more
clouds because of it though look at her
we're talking about her now but she's
stupid
so no one wants a dinner good a Marcela
do you I don't know I think more people
want a dater now absolute choice all
weekend with you
[Music]
[Music]